[APPLAUSE]
ROB DELANEY: Thank you.
Hi.
Hello, everyone.
Actually, this is what picks
me up, so this is just a prop.
It doesn't even matter.
I can do that.
Get away from me.
Thank you all for coming.
I don't know why
you're here, meaning,
like, do you work here, and
you were forced to attend?
Somebody shook your head.
You don't work here?
AUDIENCE: No.
ROB DELANEY: Great.
OK, that's good.
Then that means at least he
wasn't forced to come here.
You have a Google shirt on.
You don't know who I am.
You wish you were somewhere
else, but you're smiling.
That's OK.
Thank you.
You have the book.
Maybe you paid for it,
maybe it was a gift.
I don't know.
In any case, thank you for
coming to see me here now.
I appreciate that.
And thank you, Jason.
You could have dressed up.
You kind of dressed like
a slob to introduce me.
The joke there is that I'm
wearing the exact same thing.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: The
Mitt Romney thing.
Yeah, I played him
for "Funny or Die."
So what?
But then I got invited to
the Obama headquarters.
That's true, and I'll just
talk about that for a second
before I read the book.
What's funny is I had written
I think that it's probably
a good idea to make access
to health care easier
in the United States.
That's a radical
position that I hold,
and I've written
about that a lot.
And I didn't really care--
like I'm not a Democrat.
I'm not a Republican.
I just vote like on the issues.
And health care I liked a
lot, so I wrote a lot of stuff
about that.
And then the Obama
administration
contacted me and said,
it seems like you
care about health care.
Would you want to
maybe do ba liddle da?
And I was like, well, let
me tell you how I feel,
and you can tell
me, because I bet
I can tell you some things
that'll make you not
want to have anything
to do with me.
And I told them,
I was like, I want
Barack Obama to be reelected
as much as Michelle wants him
to be reelected, but not
because I care about him.
I mean he's some
insane millionaire
with the mental
problems that you
need to want to be president.
So I didn't ever wear a
Hope t-shirt or anything
crazy like that, you
weird sloganeers.
So I was like, but
that said, I'm insane,
so I'll happily go around the
country talking about health
care policy and all
that, why it's important,
but I might not even
say the name Obama.
And they were like, it's
been great speaking with you.
But then as it got closer, and
I started to talk more fervently
and began to just like brutalize
Mitt Romney in a real--
you know, I studied Karl
Rove and his scummery,
and it seemed like a great way.
So I just went after him just
because it was funny to me.
I remember he personally
like outlawed forever assault
weapons in Massachusetts,
which is where I grew up,
so I'd followed him for a lot
longer than a lot of people
had.
And then three years later,
in 2007, he joined the NRA.
So just watching him, I was
like-- and the health care
thing.
Anyway, even Google now is like,
why did we invite him to talk?
So I just was nuts about
the Affordable Care
Act and its awesome
website, right Google?
And it's OK to admit that that
is garbage and embarrassing.
So then, finally, they
did invite me, though,
because I did work so hard
to help Obama get reelected.
And I was there election
night, and it was pretty fun.
It was pretty fun.
My wife was pregnant
with our second kid.
And she's a woman, so she
has a uterus and a vagina.
And so there are
people who like,
well, women should pay a million
dollars to get a pap smear,
and men should get free,
blow-up "Penthouse" blah, blah.
Anyway, drives me crazy.
So anyway, that was just a way
to kill some time because I'm
secretly afraid
to speak in public
and read from my own book.
No.
So I'll tell you.
Why the hell did I write a book?
A lot of people know me from
Twitter, which is great,
and I had been doing stand-up
for a long time before that.
And then in 2010, Julie Grau
from Spiegel and Grau, who
published this book, wrote me
on Twitter and she just like,
at replied me, like the
way you would say, hey,
want to grab a club
sandwich, Rick?
Like to your friend?
And she said, hey, would
you write a book for me?
And I wrote, OK, and
then forgot about it
because I didn't
know who she was.
I'm sorry, I didn't
And then Matt Johnson, an
amazing, real author and guy
that I know wrote me, and
he said, hey, asshole,
you need to pay
attention to that.
She's like legitimately
a towering figure
in the publishing world, and
you're an asshole, again.
He said it twice.
And so I wrote her
back, and I was like,
yeah, remember when I was like,
yeah, that was just joking.
I mean, I want to,
but I didn't mean
to so cavalierly,
what do I-- how?
And so we started talking, and
I said to her, I was like, well,
you know-- I live in Los
Angeles-- and I said to her,
I was like, it so happens
I've got a show next month
in New York, just
trying to be so casual,
and maybe you could come.
And then she was like, OK.
And so then I immediately called
every theater in New York,
I have to do a show
next month in New York.
Because I didn't
really have one.
And [MOCK YELLING]
and I found one.
And then I was like, yeah,
oh, I forgot the information
because I have so
many shows, I forgot.
And here it is, and
told her where it was.
I'm going to try to
just gradually move
this throughout the thing.
And so we started talking,
and she came to my show
with her team.
And they read all the stuff
that I'd written for "Vice"
and saw my stand-up, which is
very-- if you did find me first
on Twitter, you'd be
forgiven if you thought
that my stand-up was like Steven
Wrighty or Mitch Hedbergy,
like short joke.
But it totally isn't.
It's like super long,
autobiographical, meandering
just shit, really awful, which
is to say it's longer stuff.
So this wasn't a crazy
departure for me,
even though some people
would be forgiven
for thinking that it is.
So I started to
write the book, and I
wanted it to be
a-- I love memoirs,
and I love autobiographies.
But my favorite ones aren't
ones where it was like, well,
my parents met at
blah, blah, and then
I was born at X hospital.
Who cares?
We all have our own
version of that,
and I'm not interested in yours,
so why would I be in mine?
So I wanted it to be true.
First of all, err towards
the side of humor,
and then deal with
some of the things.
Because yes, I'm
very, very lucky
to be able to make a
living doing comedy,
but I've been through
some darker stuff,
like anybody who survives
to adulthood has.
But some of my stuff was
just a little more dramatic,
I mean, the thing that sort of
divides my life into two halves
was 11 years ago.
In a blackout, I drove a
car into the Department
of Water and Power
in Los Angeles,
and I broke both
my arms very badly.
This bone was sticking out.
It was a compound fracture.
I had to have surgery
on both of them.
So I was in jail in a
wheelchair in a bloody hospital
gown from face blood.
And my legs were also in
these leg stabilizer things
because my knees had been
ripped open to the bone.
So my legs couldn't bend,
and my arms didn't work,
and I was in a hospital gown.
Sometimes in jail I'd just
slide out of the wheelchair,
and my hospital
gown would come up,
exposing everything
to everybody in jail.
And if you've been
in jail, you know
that you're supposed to
keep that stuff to yourself.
And so that's when
I was like, oh, I
should live my life in a
different manner from now on,
or I'll definitely
die or kill people.
For me, it was kind of
like, I didn't care,
like a lot of drug
addicts and alcoholics,
I was like I could have
died at any moment,
and I was totally
at peace with that.
But once the cops
were like, you know,
it's pretty amazing you
didn't kill 30 people tonight.
And I was like, you're correct.
And so once that was
driven home for me,
that's when I decided to put
the plug in the proverbial jug.
And so that's sort of
divides my life in half.
And it was only after
that, it was some months
after that when I got my first
cast off or my last cast off
and was halfway through all
the occupational therapy
I needed that I first
did my first open mic
and did stand-up and stuff.
So that sort of very
neatly divides my life
into two halves.
And then after that, I met
a woman and we got married,
and we have two kids
and all this stuff
and began to make
my living in comedy.
So that's all
dealt with in here.
But now I'm going to read
a little of it for you,
and if you fucking interrupt
me-- no, I'm just kidding.
They didn't tell if I shouldn't
swear or not, but I did.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: So this
section is called
La Mer, which is
French for the sea.
All the chapter
titles are in French
because I thought that would
be a funny, pretentious asshole
thing to do, and I did.
So here we go.
La Mer.
For two summers during
college, 1997 and 1998,
I quit New York for
Marblehead and drove
a boat called a launch
on Marblehead Harbor.
A launch is a glorified water
taxi that takes rich people out
to the middle of the harbor
where their boats are moored.
Marblehead, a town of 20,000
souls, has five yacht clubs.
I'd be very surprised if there
were another town on our planet
that had a higher number
of yacht clubs per capita.
The Eastern Boston, Dolphin,
and Marblehead Yacht Clubs
had their own launch services.
The Crescent Yacht
Club employed me,
and I drove its members
exclusively from the dock
to their various opulent
sailboats and power boats.
Our busiest day and
night of the summer
was always the 4th of July.
A wealthy community,
Marblehead could
afford to mount a high-quality
fireworks display.
Also, since Marblehead is a
peninsula with a large island
that's attached by
a thin causeway,
its natural harbor is both
protected from the open sea
and surrounded by
land on three sides.
So the harbor is
several square miles
of water filled with
around 2,000 boats ringed
by beaches and docks and parks.
You'd be hard pressed to find a
better place to drink 14 beers
and watch fireworks.
Though my earliest
4th of July's found
me sitting on my dad's
shoulders and watching fireworks
from the beach, after
puberty I saw the holiday
as one of the few
days of the year
when it was perfectly acceptable
to drink into unconsciousness.
The launch would operate nonstop
on the 4th, ferrying people
to and from their boats.
Then, after the fireworks, my
fellow launch operators and I
would respond to radio calls
and pick up families with kids,
old couples, and
dangerously-crowded motorboats
filled with drunk
people in their 20s.
Our staff consisted of our boss,
Dockmaster Bill, my high school
friend and band mate Michael.
Our band was called
Scaramanga, and it
was named after
Francisco Scaramanga
from "The Man with the Golden
Gun," the James Bond movie.
In that movie,
Francisco Scaramanga--
they've never seen
a picture of him,
but they know that he has
the identifying feature
of having a third nipple.
So Sean Connery
as James Bond has
to pose as him at one point,
and the way that he does it,
he just puts on a
prosthetic third nipple.
And the occassionally would
be like, yeah, I'm him.
And they're like, oh, OK,
come on in and play baccarat
with us.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: So Bill was
a salty dog in his 40s
who'd grown up on
the water and worked
at the Crescent for
at least 10 years.
Michael and I had
known each other
since we were about seven,
and then became very close
in high school when we both
were heavily involved in theater
as well as drinking and
talking about boobs.
Our work day finished
up at 11:00 PM,
and then we were free to
get into whatever trouble
we felt like getting into.
For Michael and me,
in the summer of 1998,
that meant getting drunk,
appropriating a little dinghy
that belonged to the yacht
club, and using it to cruise
around the harbor to see
who was out and about.
It wasn't rare for us to take
the 12-foot motorboat out
for a drunken cruise in
the middle of the night.
We'd do this a few
times every summer
with no real fear of getting
in trouble, since drunken
shenanigans on the high
seas of Massachusetts
are as run of the mill
as moustaches on cops.
Being filled with
beer and on the water
is something people have been
doing since they figured out
how to ferment hops, and
it's easy to understand why.
It's fun, and it feels good.
You've thinned your blood
with the alcohol that's
sloshing around in your
belly, complementing the rise
and fall of the sea
you're floating upon.
It just feels right to
have booze in your guts
as you float around mother
ocean like a dumb, fat buoy
at the mercy of the sea
and filled with spirits.
Sailors refer to the
ocean as "the drink"
too, as in, I slipped and
grabbed for a halyard,
and my wrench fell in the drink.
So there's clearly something
substantial and enduring
to this alcohol/sea connection.
Sometimes Michael and I would
putt out to Children's Island,
an island about a mile beyond
the the mouth of the harbor,
and go for a stroll.
Growing up, I'd gone to day camp
on Children's Island for years,
and it felt entirely
naughty to trespass on it
as a drunken adult.
Like most islands
around New England,
it smelled like seagull
shit and wild grass.
I'm sure if I caught a whiff of
it right now, I'd start crying.
When I was a counselor
on the island,
I'd had to become a
certified life guard.
Part of the training consisted
of an overnight springtime
visit to the island,
where we were supposed
to practice different
rescue techniques.
Upon arrival, we discovered
that the Marblehead cop
who taught the
course was insane.
He must have been
certified 40 years ago
over the telephone or something.
Clearly, no one was
checking up on him
because he had
gone entirely rogue
and used educational techniques
that were, I now realize,
abusive.
The most memorable
thing he did was
show us a slideshow of
actual dead drowning
victims from Marblehead
Police files.
He began the
slideshow by asking,
what's the difference
between a saltwater
drowning and a
freshwater drowning?
I'll tell you.
Saltwater animals eat people.
Freshwater animals don't.
So when you find someone
who's drowned in saltwater,
they'll have been
eaten somewhat.
And when you find someone
who's drowned in freshwater,
they'll be all bloated up.
So what you find is horrible,
just in two different ways.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: He then
got a slide projector,
positioned it in front of a
white sheet that was suspended
in front of a fireplace,
and started showing us
pictures of a variety of
corpses that had been pulled out
of the water a few miles
in various directions
from where we sat
in our sleeping
bags in a lodge on a
small island in the middle
of the dark, terrifying night.
My friend Ellen was there.
We were adhered to
each other in fear
as he clicked from
corpse to corpse.
The island didn't
have electricity,
so the slide projector was
powered by a portable gas
generator that hummed
outside the building,
efficiently masking the
sounds of any approaching
ghosts or child murderers.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: One particularly
ghastly saltwater
drowning victim was
a skeleton whose meat
had been almost entirely
removed from it.
Almost.
The gut contents
within the ribcage
had proven difficult
to access for the fish
and bottom feeders, so the
ribs rather effectively
caged a rotten buffet of guts
that poked out the bottom
and protruded between the ribs.
The slide that
followed, that was
of a dead baby, a
fucking dead baby.
And since this baby had
drowned in freshwater,
it was bloated and huge.
Next photo was a close up of
the dead baby's bloated face.
We cringed, and then the
screen immediately went black,
and the generator went out.
Then it came back on.
Then off again.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: The
generator sputtered.
The dead baby's face
strobed on and off
as the generator outside choked
and a room full of 16-year-olds
screamed.
What in Christ's fuck did this
have to do with life guarding?
20 years later, my best
guess remains, not a thing.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: Officer
Soul Murder went out
to check on the generator.
And when he returned,
he said, bad news.
The generator broke.
We shuddered in relief,
and then went outside
to practice moving people
with spine injuries
from one end of the
island to another.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: I'm going
to leave it there.
And here's another one, another
semi-nautically themed one.
Man, even reading that.
That fucking happened.
What an asshole.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: This one's
called Le Courage.
One night in the
summer of 1999 I
jumped off the Manhattan Bridge.
It wasn't a suicide attempt.
I had a bungee cord
attached to my ankles.
But it was still illegal and
not part of any tour package
or team-building exercise.
I'd just graduated
from NYU and was
working as a waiter
at the Atlantic Grill
on the Upper East Side.
Right before I graduated, I
booked the role of Sir Lancelot
in a touring company
of "Camelot."
But the tour didn't begin
rehearsals until fall,
so I spent the summer
waiting tables.
The night in question
I ate probably
25 pieces of exotic sushi
that patrons had left
untouched on their plates.
Rich people ate at the
restaurant and thought nothing
of ordering $200 worth of
sushi and eating half of it.
What was I supposed
to do, not eat it?
At around 11, I split up
my tips with the busboys,
then headed out and took the
6 train back to Alphabet City,
planning to drink a 12-pack of
Lowenbrau without assistance.
When I got back to my
apartment, my roommate Kish
was pacing around and smiling.
"Guess what I'm going to
do tonight?" he asked.
"What?" "I'm going to bungee
jump off the Manhattan Bridge."
I'd met Kish during my
junior year in Paris.
I'd been drawn to him
immediately because he
was a smart, fun,
well-read guy who
was always up for adventure.
He was named for an island in
the Persian Gulf off of Iran,
which is where his
father Menushar was born.
Menushar had an archetypal
entrance to the United States
in 1963, when the boat that
took him across the Atlantic
encountered fog as
it approached land.
After a period of
very low visibility,
the Statue of Liberty
herself emerged from the fog,
looming over the boat, welcoming
them to the United States.
Rather than ask Kish any
questions like, why are you
jumping off the
Manhattan Bridge?,
I told him I was
coming with him.
And we headed out the door
to meet "some guy" who
has a bungee cord near
the Brooklyn on-ramp
to the Manhattan Bridge.
Kish didn't know the
cord owner, but he
did know a Polish
guy who knew him,
so we went to meet his
friend Dariosh at a bar.
I didn't know Dariosh, but
he endeared himself to me
by immediately launching
into a story about how he'd
learned the hard way earlier
that day that wearing
a tiny Speedo bathing
suit to the beach
draws a lot of
attention in the US.
He presented Kish and me
with a cogent argument
as to why Speedo
suits are superior
and why American men were
silly for not wearing them.
We told him that he
made a great case,
but that American women tended
to prefer a little mystery
where a man's junk
dimensions were concerned,
even though solving
such a mystery
might involve facing down
a disappointing penis
lurking in the
shadow of a fat gut
after drinking a
bucket of wine coolers
at a rented beach house.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: Dariosh
was pretty fit,
though, so I'm sure his
ensemble made some people happy.
After bonding with
Dariosh we headed out
to meet the guy who'd show
us how to jump off a bridge.
About 15 people were
gathered on a busy corner
of Flatbush Avenue waiting
for the guy with the rope.
For something wholly illegal
and intrinsically dangerous,
it was a rather
well-advertised operation.
After a few minutes,
Tony arrived and led us
along Flatbush Avenue toward
the on-ramp to the bridge.
As we traveled, Tony gave
us instructions, including
the order to lie down if the
subway passed us on the bridge
so that conductors
wouldn't see us.
Tony had me carry
the bungee cord
up the bridge in a big bag.
It weighed maybe 50
pounds, and I told myself
its substantial weight meant
that it must be really safe.
When we'd covered
some distance, he
handed out walkie talkies
set to the police frequency
to a few of the customers.
He'd asked us to
give him $20 apiece.
He told us to listen for any
discussion among the cops
about a large group of people
sneaking out onto the Manhattan
Bridge with crazy gear.
He said that it'd
be hard to get away
if they wanted to arrest us, so
what we were really listening
to was for any mention
of Truck 2 or Truck 6.
He said that those
names referred
to tactical
anti-terrorist units that
would kill us first and
then figure out who we were.
He said if we heard that
those groups were being sent
to the bridge, we should
just drop everything, run,
and not stop until we
were in New Jersey.
I listened very carefully
for Trucks 2 and 6
for the next few hours.
We walked out over the East
River, hitting the deck
whenever a train came by,
and made it about one eighth
of a mile from
the Brooklyn shore
and then set up our station.
Our first instructions
from Tony were
to climb down a
level on the bridge
and-- I swear to god--
disable the red lights
that hang from the bridge
to alert airplanes, hello, I
am a bridge.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: I'm
sure that today,
after 9/11, New York law
enforcement would Truck 6
your ass off for that stunt.
But our adventure took place
two years prior to the attack,
so we didn't imagine anyone
would be too upset that we were
turning a piece of vital
metropolitan infrastructure
into an amusement park ride
and making it partially
invisible to air traffic.
Then Tony, who claimed to
be a theatrical rigger,
took out the bungee cord
and secured it to something.
To what?
To a piece of bridge, I guess.
I have no idea.
Then Tony asked who
wanted to go first,
and a short guy with a
buzz cut volunteered.
Before he let the
test subject jump,
Tony thrust a tape
recorder in the guy's face.
"What is your name?" "Dave."
"What are you about to do?"
"Jump off the
Manhattan Bridge." "Are
you doing this of your own
volition?" "Yes." "Jump."
The guy jumped, screaming.
It was loud for a fraction of
a second, then immediately much
quieter, as though someone had
very quickly turned a volume
knob down.
The reason his screaming
got quieter to us
is that he had just
jumped off a bridge.
I looked over the edge, and he
had disappeared into the black.
Disabling the bridge's lights
had effectively shrouded us
in inky darkness.
I very sincerely believed
the rope had broken,
and he had gone into the river.
I was certain I'd
helped facilitate
the death of someone,
someone stupid like me.
But then Tony yelled, "You
all right down there?"
And the test subject
meowed a weak, "Yes."
Then a cop car pulled up at
the water's edge in Brooklyn.
There was no activity
on the scanners,
but Tony yell-whispered
down to jumper one,
"Just chill out for a second.
Don't move."
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: Kish and I looked
at each other, incredulous.
Don't move?
What if his head filled
with blood and exploded?
How long can a person
hang upside down
without passing out or
becoming permanently stupid?
What if Truck 6 fired a missile
up his defenseless asshole?
After a few terrifying
minutes, the cop
left not having seen us.
We threw another
rope with a carabiner
down to dangling Dave.
He hooked it on to his
waist, and we manually
pulled him back
up to the bridge.
I calculated that he probably
weighed 75% of what I weighed,
so there was probably a three
out of four chance I'd survive.
He said whoa a
bunch, in a manner
that suggested he was properly
odd, but not necessarily
retarded after the rush
of blood to his head.
Good enough for me.
Then it was my turn.
Though I counted maybe 11
reasons as to why I shouldn't
jump, several of them
potentially fatal or crippling,
and all of them criminal,
I was determined
to have a stranger tie
a rope around my ankles
and leap off that bridge at
3:00 in the morning as planned.
Tony stuck his tape
recorder in my face.
"What is your name?"
"Rob Delaney."
I must point out that
Kish made fun of me
without interruption for
several years at how much
naked fear was audible in
my shaky, high-pitched voice
as I answered Tony's questions.
"What are you
about to do?" "Jump
off the Manhattan
Bridge." "Are you
doing this of your own
volition?" "Yes." "Jump."
I jumped.
I looked out over a
sleepy, twinkling Manhattan
as I plummeted into the night.
It was wonderful and visceral,
like my mind and body
were violently wiped
clean and rebooted
to take in the majesty
of the experience.
It felt like a
reverse birth as I
flew into and through the
darkness toward the river.
Then the slack in the cord
tightened as my rocketing mass
stretched it to its limit, and
I shot skyward and bridgeward
almost as fast as I'd descended.
I made it almost to the
bridge, then fell again,
and began a series of bounces.
It was like being
in a giant glitter
globe as the city's
lights shock around me.
I felt entirely buoyed
and supported and loved
by the dirty river, the ugly
bridge, the beautiful city,
and the questionable rope.
Then Tony threw down
the yank-him-up rope.
And after it swung
past me a few times,
I was able to grab it,
hook it to my waist,
and get pulled back up to the
bridge by my fellow jumpers.
Then Kish and the others
jumped, one by one,
and we pulled them back up.
We packed up as the sun rose and
took the train home to Alphabet
City to sleep, arriving
in full daylight.
It had been entirely
magnificent to watch
about 20 people in a row
have an experience you knew
they'd talk about for
the rest of their lives
and participate in it as well.
It was interesting to see
the few people who backed out
so totally at peace
with their decision too.
Nobody gave them a
hard time either.
I know I thought,
well, of course
you didn't want to
jump off a bridge.
Why would anyone do that?
That would be crazy.
Those of us who had jumped
were pretty much aglow.
As my reflections began
to gather and coalesce
in my brain, I was absolutely
glad I had done it.
But I knew I would
never do it again,
nor would I allow a loved
one or really anyone
to do it since I'd seen how
ramshackle an operation it was.
It was a singular rush and an
extraordinarily terrible idea
all at once.
And while I have difficulty
imagining a scenario where I do
something that reckless again,
I'm very happy I can say I
jumped off the Manhattan Bridge,
and you, statistically, cannot.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB DELANEY: So if you
have questions or anything,
now would be the time for that.
Thank you very much.
This is the first I've ever
read that out loud to people,
so thanks for listening.
You do the Q's,
and I do the A's.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rob.
Thanks for coming.
ROB DELANEY: Thanks
for having me.
AUDIENCE: You're probably
the most prominent example
of someone, of a comedian,
especially, now, who
has made their name almost
exclusively through the web.
Do you think that model
is kind of here to stay,
or do you think that
there will always
be a place for comedians to
kind of just go on the road
and work the clubs and do it the
way it's been done for years?
ROB DELANEY: I'm going
to repeat that question.
So I know you guys all heard
it, but they told me to,
so I'm going to.
Do I think that the
web is here to stay?
Can you still achieve notoriety
slash fame slash a career
through touring and the
old-fashioned methods
of getting your name out there?
I sort of think that it is
here to stay, of course,
or it'll morph into
whatever the next thing is.
But a variation
on what we see now
will endure, assuming there
isn't a singularity T2
situation where
electricity stops existing
or there's a nuclear
winter, which is, also, we
have to be prepared for that.
But it would be,
in my opinion, it
would be silly to not
avail yourself of the tools
that are here now.
For example, to
give you a timeline
and explain it explicitly, I
did stand-up for the first time
in 2002.
Then in 2007, I
lost another day job
and thought, OK,
now I'm going to be
a comedian full time in 2007.
In 2009, I joined Twitter.
And then in 2010
was the last time
I collected a paycheck for
anything other than comedy.
So it's been about
3 and 1/2 years
that I've made my
living through comedy.
I pursued a career through
all the traditional channels,
but then the internet
helped me, certainly,
catapult a few strata.
So I think that it's almost like
once public transportation came
into play.
It's like, would you take the
subway to get to gigs in 1956
or whatever?
Yeah, because if you
don't, then Dave will,
and you'll get to the club
on your horse and buggy
like way after his
people are clapping,
and women are just
throwing their clothing,
and people are bringing
buffets of hot, assorted meat.
You know what I mean?
So it's here.
It's not good.
It's not bad.
It's just what's happening.
You know what I mean?
Like my head might explode
from a sniper's bullet.
But the internet, I don't
think, has improved lives.
You can just do more faster,
but you're still doing more.
Like so that sucks.
But you can do it
faster, and that's cool.
So I think it's sort of
like a net zero thing.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
spin-off question
is, as someone who has sort
of made their name on the web,
do you run into resistance
from established industry types
who kind of resent
the fact that you
didn't go through the
traditional route?
ROB DELANEY: Only from
small-minded people
who aren't good
at what they do--
and that's not even
a joke-- and aren't
good in that traditional realm.
Somebody who's sincerely
funny, why would they care?
You know what I mean?
So no.
And also it's so hard to
make it as a comedian.
Twitter gets me in the
door, but of a club?
People don't care.
Like I would be bodily
thrown out of a club
if I didn't deliver
once I got in there.
So thank god I had been
sharpening my sword
before Twitter ever
came on the scene.
So not really.
And nor do I care
that there are people
who find out about me
from Twitter first.
Great.
I mean, as recently as
3 and 1/2 years ago,
I worked telemarketing in
a dirty basement boiler
room near the airport selling
a garbage financial newspaper
and would call
people and be like,
do you want this
terrible newspaper?
And they'd be like, no,
why are you bothering me?
And I'd be like, I am so sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: You know, making
less than minimum wage.
So I'm not going
to be like, yeah, I
wish that it was 15 years
in the Comedy Cellar
that got me to where I am now.
I can perform at the
Comedy Cellar now.
And if it didn't work
out when I was there,
then they would say, get out
of here and don't come back.
So it's sort of like
it's here, so use it.
And that's my answer to that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
ROB DELANEY: I hope
it answered it.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Rob.
You sound like you had
some interesting jobs
before you became a
full-time comedian.
Can you talk about
those, and how
they influenced
your comedy today?
ROB DELANEY: Yeah.
Yeah, other jobs that I've had
that have influenced my comedy.
I mean, I worked in a
factory for a couple of years
where we made snow plows
for Chicago subway trains.
And we made conveyor-- this
is terrible-- we made conveyor
belts for tobacco
companies that they could
sort their tobacco on and
kill our grandparents with.
But working in a factory
is very applicable
because the thing
about-- like the best
comedians, like a Jerry
Seinfeld, or a Louis
CK, or a Chris Rock, or a Sarah
Silverman, or a Maria Bamford,
or a Joan Rivers, one thing
that unites all of them,
that might not be the first
thing that a layman would
think of, is work ethic.
Those people work, and
that's so sexy to me.
They go to the factory every
day, and they do the deal,
and they always get better.
Like Sarah Silverman, I see
her do a lot of shows in LA.
She's been famous for a long
time, still getting better.
You know what I mean?
Still improving.
Watching her hone jokes
is so inspiring and cool.
Or Louis CK, an amazing
touring schedule
while making his own
TV show that he writes,
produces, directs,
edits, and stars in.
So factory work, like
it's an honorable thing
to punch in every day, do
your work and whatever.
It might not be
glamorous, but so what?
You can definitely
apply that elbow grease
to your glamorous career as
a whatever in entertainment,
and then your
career will endure.
So yeah, there isn't
a career that I've
had that doesn't translate into.
Oh, and I worked at a company
called Intermix Media in 2004.
Was it 2003 or 2004?
And this company
bought a company
called Response
Base in California.
Response Base
"invented" Myspace, OK,
and so I was one of the first
people to work at Myspace.
I sold the first ads
on Myspace, and I
wrote like email subject
lines and stuff like that.
I would test subject
lines against each other.
And that only hit me
like a few months ago.
I was like, maybe that's why
I can write a tweet because I
scientifically tested
horrible spam email things
and used math to determine how
to burrow into people's brains
like a horrible criminal.
You know what I mean?
So if what you're doing right
now is what you want to do,
that's awesome.
If it isn't?
The thing that
you do want to do,
you'll be able to use what
you're doing right now.
So it's all interdisciplinary.
It all informs each other.
That's my answer
to your question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROB DELANEY: Thank you.
Like a question from a woman?
Oh, thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It's like
I'm being interrogated.
Hi.
ROB DELANEY: Hi,
being interrogated.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious about how
you feel about all these
things from your life
that you've now written
about and kind of enshrined
in this book.
I mean, it just came
out, and maybe you're
not used to reading from it
or talking about it as much.
But perhaps you've used it
in your stand-up as well.
How do you feel about
these pieces of your life
that are now becoming
kind of something else?
ROB DELANEY: Yeah.
How do I feel about
personal things
that I've experienced,
aspects of my life,
becoming more public and,
in fact, being frozen--
AUDIENCE: Right.
ROB DELANEY: --as they are?
AUDIENCE: And do
they kind of still
exist in some real
way in your brain,
and what is your
relationship to them now
that they're on the page,
or they're on the stage,
or wherever they are?
ROB DELANEY: I do
like seeing something
that I can't monkey
with anymore.
You know what I mean?
This book, these stories
are these stories.
I can't really
revise them anymore.
And that's kind of cool
because with stand-up you're
always doing that.
And I enjoy that too,
but it's nice to have
to put something down.
I read something that
Joyce Carol Oates
tweeted the other
day about how it
was cool to have finality with
a typewriter and ink and paper.
Like when something
was done, it was done.
And that's really
cool, and that's
a form of confinement,
stricture, finishing.
Like I like the 140
characters of a tweet.
Like Picasso had
his Blue Period.
So it is cool.
I heard a kindergarten teacher
saying-- it's like apocryphal,
you've probably heard
it-- where they were like,
oh, your kids make
the best drawings.
How do you do it?
And the teachers
like, I just know
when to take it
away from the kids,
so they don't make it a
crowded piece of kid garbage.
So I do like things like
restrictions and things
being like, nope, that's done.
Take it away.
So just from like an artistic
perspective, I like that.
But then as far as people
seeing stuff about me,
I sort of have had practice
with that, with like magazine
articles that I've
written, doing stand-up,
so having done stuff
in the public eye.
So yeah, I'm
proprietary about it.
That happened to me.
That's my story.
It's not anybody else's
unless they're in it.
And I don't know.
It made me happy just
reading these just now,
and this is my first
reading since the book just
came out yesterday.
So I just tried to approach
it all sort of compassionately
and be nice but thorough
with my history.
So I don't feel
revealed or anything.
Also, since a lot of stuff
is of a sensitive nature,
writing the book wasn't
really therapeutic for me
because I had waited so
long to write about things
like alcoholism,
sobriety, depression,
when I had really gone
through formal therapy
and healed to some degree
with the deadlier things.
So now I don't read this
and think like, ooh, ooh.
Whereas had I written it,
I think, irresponsibly,
which is to say maybe
seven or eight years ago,
then maybe it might have
been a little scarier
to put it out there.
But I'm sort of at
peace with everything,
and this book was written
from a place of, I feel,
mental health or the best
version of mental health
that I can approximate.
So I don't know if I
answered your question,
but I did talk for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROB DELANEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
On Pete Holmes' "You
Made It Weird" podcast,
you talked about like
this black hole of death
while you were singing the
national anthem the first time,
I think.
And I'm just curious,
does that keep
coming up every--
because you've done it
multiple times, from
what I understand?
ROB DELANEY: Ah, yes.
Yeah.
And the answer to that is no.
I have sung the national anthem
at five or so Red Sox games
at Fenway Park in
five or so games.
And what he's talking about,
I sang the national anthem
for the first time at
Fenway Park in 2004,
the year the Red Sox won the
World Series for the first time
in 86 years.
And do I take credit for that?
A little bit.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: And the
way that happened
is I studied musical
theater in college at NYU,
and I had a friend who
worked for the Red Sox.
And she said, hey,
there's 180 games a year,
we can't always
get someone good.
Could you do it one time?
And so I was like,
yes, and so I did it.
And the public address system
at Fenway Park is 700 years old,
and so when you sing, you
hear an echo of yourself
because you're in a very large
place, but there's a delay.
So you say, oh say, and then
like a second and a half
later, you hear back to
you, thundering much louder
than it came out
your body, oh say.
But that's when you're
already a little bit
ahead into the next thing.
So you're like you're
doing a duet with yourself
from the past, out of rhythm,
in this like syncopated singing
what is known to be the
hardest song there is.
Like the national anthem,
cool song, spans octaves.
The reason people
screw it up, and they
pass around YouTube
videos of it,
is because it's a
hard song to sing.
It's not because
they're bad or an idiot.
The words don't make sense.
It's just like a list of stuff--
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: --literally.
Like it's not a ballad,
where it's like, and then
a thing naturally happened
that makes sense from the.
Literally, it's like "The
Joker" by Steve Miller
might as well be
our national anthem.
So you're singing
the hardest song
in the world in the
most hallowed baseball
park in America.
It's the town that I grew up in.
Fully sold out, with
an echo from-- I mean,
it's like imagine if
somebody was like,
I dare you to do good
at this hard thing
while you're doing it.
And so I was so nervous that
literally my vision went
like ppvvvvvvvvvvvvvv,
and I could see this,
and I literally disconnected.
I totally had like a
Sufi mystical experience,
where I was like-- literally,
this is what I thought.
I was like the anthem
needs to be sung.
I am the vessel through
which it must come to Earth.
So I was like, get your ego--
I'm not singing the anthem.
The anthem must be sung.
All these people
need to hear it.
So my fears mean nothing.
I literally was like,
be a diaphanous fabric
that God can dance about.
I literally was like oodolodolo.
So I sang it.
Don't remember it at all.
And then when they cut-- OK.
So I go like, and the
home of the brave,
and I went braaave, llaaarrghh.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: But that
happens so often,
that people deflate
and like blluurgh,
that they know to cut the sound.
So I was like, oh, my
god, everybody heard that.
And they were like,
nobody heard it
except the sound engineer,
who was like, yep,
here's the uurrrgh.
OK, turn it off.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB DELANEY: So yes, I've never.
Oh, but now?
I can't get nervous.
I could perform
it-- like I could
be being shot at in front
of a million people.
I'd be like, it's
not a big deal.
Like so that was good.
That was good for my
comedy that I did that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROB DELANEY: Thanks.
ROB DELANEY: Well,
I guess-- hello.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Does this work?
Yeah.
Thank you for coming in
You're a great reader.
ROB DELANEY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROB DELANEY: He said
I'm a great reader,
if you didn't hear that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm
wondering if you've
seen kind of the
evolution of Twitter
and all the other technology
that's coming out?
Have there been shortcomings
in those platforms
that you've kind of
seen that haven't
let you emphasize
your comedy enough?
You're using YouTube,
but then Vine came out,
other things like
that, that you wish
was an easier platform to use
to get your comedy out there?
ROB DELANEY: That's
an excellent question.
Have I seen shortcomings in
other emerging technologies
that I wish I could use better,
or could just be used better,
could be implemented?
I think they're trying to do it.
And this is kind of nerdy, but
I might be in the right place
to talk about that.
From just like an
e-commerce perspective,
it might be cool for people
like me and other people
to be able-- if you could
like buy stuff within Twitter.
If there was like
a shopping cart
in there, that would kind
of be cool because then you
could be like, oh, I don't
have to go three websites away.
Now that everybody
knows everything
to the point of
insanity about us,
and it's plenty easy
to share information
across different
things, it would kind of
be cool if you could
be like, blooh,
now I own that thing
he was talking about
and can consume it on my
larger screen at home tonight
with my family.
Of course, that'll
definitely be happening,
but that's one thing
that would be cool.
Vine didn't really call to me.
The thing I like about Twitter
is that the best tweets
are the ones that don't
have links in them
and the ones where-- because you
have to use your imagination.
Like I've found that when
I would ever meet people
in real life that I knew on like
Friendster, or then Myspace,
or then Facebook,
the people that I've
met from social networks
before and enjoyed the most
being around are usually
people from Twitter
because I think
you have to distill
your purist essence of who you
are into the 140 characters.
So it's just sort of weird
how somebody on Facebook
can have 800 pictures
and blah, and be
like, this is the self
I wish to present.
And it's not as
clear as somebody
who you get a sense
of from really reading
the thing that they had to
squeeze and distill and diamond
compress into their
little tweet box.
So other technologies.
And also, I've totally put my
eggs in the Twitter basket.
So people would say to
me when Vine came out,
why don't you have a Vine?
I'd be like, oh, you
know, because there's
24 hours in a day, that's
why I don't have a Vine,
and I would like
to pay attention
to my family for
a couple of them.
And so shortcomings?
Twitter's pretty cool.
Every new thing they add,
I typically don't really
need it because I sort of use
it in like the purest way,
like not linking, not whatever.
But I've been pretty
satisfied with it.
There are certain things.
Like sometimes I wish there
was a built-in or natural way
for me to like figure out
who's-- I would love to have
a super "Minority Report"
dashboard for the people who
follow me so that I could be
like, so maybe these people,
because why do people in
Albuquerque need to know that
I'm going to be playing
in Cincinnati that night?
You know what I mean?
So geo-targeting crap
like that would be fun.
But Twitter, it does
what I need it to do.
Would I refine
that a little bit?
Yes.
But no other website things
tickle my fancy too much.
I don't feel that there's
anything that I can identify
like, oh, I wish this
existed and doesn't.
Like I'm not going to invent
anything any time soon
because I'm secretly very
old fashioned, and boring,
and a Luddite, and don't know
how to even do what I do.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ROB DELANEY: Thank you.
When I started working at the
company that invented Myspace,
like not even 18
months before that,
when I started working
there as a temp,
I had to ask somebody how to
turn my computer on for me.
And they were like, and you can
just drag and drop that into.
I remember after they
showed me how to turn it on,
I was like, what, drag?
I remember trying to not
cry, I was so nervous
about basic use of a computer.
Yeah.
So I think that might have
brought us full circle,
that one right there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB DELANEY: Well, thank
you so much, everybody.
You're very kind
to come and listen.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]